did you know that I
am apparently an
anti-lgbtq bigot that's true that
according to Media Matters apparently
Media Matters has a rundown of Tim
Poole's guests from the year and they
say extremists bigots and conspiracy
theorists YouTube Tip YouTuber Tim pools
2022 guests in review
and I was really honored to make the
list it's sort of a best of so they go
through all these guys you know let's
see where am I I want to skip over
everybody else I just want to get to me
they've got I think a number of other
daily wire people did too okay here we
go
uh top of the page far right figure
Lauren Southern was on Tim cast multiple
times this year Southern has a history
of pushing racist propaganda and white
nationalist rhetoric and then you get to
me the daily wires Michael Knowles is an
anti-lgbtq bully pool hosted Knowles in
April by the way pool hosted Knowles
like five days ago too so they clearly
aren't up on their extremism
and then it goes on and on but I think I
think Brett made it I think Walsh made
it like Jeremy I mean there yeah here we
go Ben Ben's on here it's it's kind of
so like maybe Drew all of us
but I I ranked up here as an anti-lgbtq
bully
I
performed in my few first musical
theater production at the age of eight
when I was a child I took
Jazz Ballroom
and tap dancing lessons
I graduated from the gayest university
in the United States
I have lived most of my life
on the coasts
a disproportionate number of my friends
are very very gay
I regularly drink port and Sherry at the
end of the night I
I just I just how did I become I like to
think I'm a nice open mind how did I
become an
anti-lgbtq bully do you know why you
know what they cite they get a link that
that phrase It's because
I said on Tim Poole's show or maybe it
was on my own show I don't remember
exactly the context I said that there's
no such thing as gay marriage that
marriage intrinsically involves sexual
difference and so because I stated a
plain fact of language and anthropology
that makes me an anti-lgbtq bully why do
I mention it one I mention it because I
absolutely adore my publicists over at
Media Matters I thank them very much for
keeping me in the news and top of
everybody's mind
the other reason I mention it is to show
you what a lie it was when when the left
told us when we were a little further up
that slippery slope
they said
listen
why do you care what people do in their
own homes
say well it's not exactly what we're
talking we're talking about political
matters you know the nature of marriage
the nature of man and woman and the
nature of the Constitution and what the
degree to which the Constitution even
has a say over these sorts of matters
and so they said well you're a come on
you're just you're just being a weirdo
why do you care what people do in their
homes okay we said do whatever you want
in your own homes okay we'll even
pretend that it's in the Constitution
that you have a right to do whatever
weird sex stuff you want to do in your
homes okay fine
all right and that's why we also need
civil unions that's all we just want
civil unions okay
just just recognize that certain legal
privileges that you can have them in a
union between two men
just as between a man and a woman
I said I don't know because it kind of
then blurs the definition they said what
do you care
why are you come on that's all we want
okay
then they said we're going to redefine
marriage they said well hold on man
marriage that's the fundamental
political institution that's a that's
for all of human history everywhere in
the world people have thought marriage
means a certain thing now you're telling
me it it doesn't mean that at all you're
actually abolishing the institution of
marriage and so that's all we want to do
that's all we want to do is just
redefine marriage a little bit but you
can you guys you can still it's not
going to threaten your marriage
you can run your business you can have
your life you can have your church okay
then what do they do they just passed
this quote unquote respect for Marriage
Act
which Outlaws
businesses refusing to participate in a
gay marriage quote unquote gay marriage
now if you are a Christian all I did
was articulate the Catholic view of
marriage which also happens to be with
some exception the Protestant view of
marriage which also happens to be the
Jewish view of marriage which also
happens to be the Muslim view of
marriage which also happens to be the
view of marriage of every
even semi-reasonable agnostic or
atheists were all Pagan for all of human
history they say it makes you a bully
that's how it goes
and had we stood a little firmer on our
principles and on reality further up
that slippery slope and had we not
allowed the libs and the squishes to
tell us to stop being such fuddy-duddies
and to just you know come on get with
the times and get hip and cool man we
wouldn't be where we are now all of the
sexual Madness that you were seeing the
castrating little kids The Pride flags
flying everywhere from our state
capitals to Kandahar the the
uh now prohibition of people to refuse
to participate in a so-called gay
marriage
all of that flows directly from those
those battles that we conceded further
up the slippery slope should it should
remind us of how to fight moving into
the future we got a lot more show coming
up it's fake headline Friday so we have
got you I need your help before you all
go to the airport and miss your flights
because the snowstorm is canceling every
flight in the country before you head
down hunker down and eat some nice
turkey or seven fishes if you're Italian
I need you to help me figure out which
is the fake headline for fake headline
Friday we've also got more voicemail
back we've also got more mailbag mailbag
the rest of the show continues now
you don't want to miss it if you're not
a member click the link in the
description and join us
[Music]
[Music]